what's up everybody happy monday it's
time for another business Q&A while we
play league of legends I'm excited I
know if you don't have anything yet
except my bottle of water I got it I got
it I woke up really early today and just
kind of cleaned up and chilled and watch
the sunrise so I mean I I'm in a good
mood today I am joined by my usual
co-host Rishi Cup TV welcome back hey
Evan good morning everyone what's up
believe nation what's in the cup today
I've got my Spanish coffee today and I
am a little bit cup of frazzled only
because i have my earphones that i had
already for this chat and they've
disappeared oh but I'm good I'm good I'm
happy to be here a couple of frazzled
well I just have a cup of water and but
cup of gratitude for Alex who's over and
just offered to make me eggs so I'm
going to make soon which will be
exciting um I'm lining up with J reyez
he wants to play rise so we're trying to
set up a game this should be fun team on
rise we are we on the streak I feel like
we are right we're on a streak did we
did we win the line no did we lose I
think we lost no we lost bad woman yeah
we library yeah we surrendered that's
terrible yeah okay new streak gonna
start today let's see how we do uh gotta
get it started gotta get it started shot
oh oh I need that all that James
watching I think he's watching trying
the new idea you gave me today so Jay
and I were talking on Friday and he he
wanted me to try a different item in my
build so I'm going to I'm gonna try that
today and see what happens it won't even
work said here's the trying things let's
do some shout outs in the chat we got
soul Forge 2453 welcomes a no Jen last
minute Louie off the sourcebook I love
it I love
I love it all right well we're trying to
get a game set up here we're in queue
let's hit up some questions what do we
got what's first okay Evan we got a
great first comment it's not a question
but I think it's a great way to start
this monday morning so we've got leave
orly as i might be saying that wrong but
she says good morning Evan thank you so
much for this video it gave me goose
flesh I'm assuming just like I was fun I
loved it hashtag hey splash yeah and she
says you are really great and I'm very
grateful to you for all the videos you
post especially the top 10 rules for
success you with your videos you give me
much more than useful info for
entrepreneurs and she actually puts a
list of the things that she wants to
thank you for so this is good coming
right off out of the gratitude journal
our gratitude a stream he says I get to
know more and more about successful
people I get to know famous people from
all over the world I get updates about
what's going on in the world I get a
tremendous amount of joy from looking at
the at the 10 rules and she says I never
watched the news I never watched sports
but I capital l-o-v-e love watching your
videos of sports people um and that's
been rich she just yeah she just was
really super grateful for the channel in
the top 10 and i'll add to that evan i
noticed on your top 10 you've got a new
kind of bumper which is awesome yeah
it's oj rise did that in collaboration
so he did all the visuals and then does
another youtube subscriber who did the
audio for us so they've been working
together on a couple of things they did
that it did the 7-way series and I think
they're working on some others so yeah
I'm glad you liked it it's good i'm a
big fan no it's really good it makes it
gets me excited too I just love things
where all of this is going but sounds
likely
is excited too though cool thank you for
the kind words at that means a lot Rishi
what's your favorite top 10 video Wow oh
my gosh okay well I always complain that
I can't keep up like I don't watch
especially like more than ever I'm upset
because you know I've have seen changes
in schedule so I'm not on as much as I
my heart wants to be on and that's one
of my biggest frustration but some that
i've really been impacted by I mean you
know that i love the oprah winfrey top
10 I also love Elizabeth Gilbert's top
10 gosh there's so many but I've also
missed a whole lot so that might not be
my final answer that's good i like it i
feel it i started tight i started
tyreese's too but i haven't been able to
get past yet the first rule but i'm
gonna get through that video I'm so
excited Tyrese Tyrese the love-hate
relationship yeah that was a great i
love that video i just hate how long it
took me to do it oh yeah it's officially
become the longest the most amount of
time I've ever put into a top 10 is that
Tyrese video I didn't know I didn't know
though it was a love-hate thing I
thought it was just like you were just
so like you just loved it well you did
love it that much that's why you took
the time yeah and also I felt like I
felt a sense of responsibility right
like I I want to be proud of everybody
that comes out and I felt like we
weren't doing him justice with what we
initially pulled and so yeah so I just
did it I spent two days do it and fell
behind on a whole bunch of other stuff
but I'm glad it's resonating people are
digging that videos a lot of great
comments in there so I'm glad people are
feeling it cool so I hope he sees it and
he hasn't seen it someone make sure he
sees it tweet tweet him up Therese
what's
we can I this video absolutely all right
well you want to get the next question
noise yeah let's do it nice got a lot of
chatter going on right now about the top
ten people are kind of turning it on
their favorite top 10 oh ok what does
have you raised yeah we got the Ellen
you know I don't think I've seen Ellen
one which is bad i would love to see
that one that comes from optus or she
says I love Ellen here yep we've got
some of the people saying love the
Elizabeth Gilbert one as well JLo
someone mentioned prince prince jay robe
oh yeah so difficult long day is that
still your in is that still your most
watched most viewed series or has that
changed since the last time I've heard
from you on that in terms of series it's
the most viewed series as we do it it's
also like we do so many of them but yeah
it's the most popular series that's
awesome oh alright uh so the question
the next question comes from Mugisha and
lisa says thanks so much Evan I want to
be a wealthy businessman but the problem
is I have a lack of money how can I
reach what I want to be all right so
yeah I think a lot of people put the
cart before the horse and they want to
be this end thing because it's kind of a
cool thing you know be a wealthy
businessman on Friday we talked a lot
about how entrepreneurship has become
just pop culture thing to do it
people want to be entrepreneurs but they
don't actually they're putting the cart
before the horse they don't actually
even have an idea of how they want to
add value and impact the world and so
anyway I think this is the same thing I
think I don't think it's bad that you
want to you know have a successful be a
successful business but I would just say
the best place to start is to not worry
about the wealthy businessmen part but
how would you want to improve the lives
of the people around you and you know
are you wanting to do a service business
or a product business just start there
and then start adding value right now
because you don't have to wait and for
anybody you just start and and that's
that yeah just focus on the impact if
you look at the people who've had the
most money and you look at we covered
this in the book in the one word book
the people had the most impact to the
stars people make the most money the
ones who didn't have money as their main
goal it was I wanted to change the way
something was done I wanted to create
this thing that hasn't been done before
I'm so frustrated with how this industry
is working or I have this big problem
myself that I want to solve that's what
that's what motivates these
entrepreneurs where if you just make
money your goal you're never going to
get there because you're going to end up
doing things just trying to make money
that you're not super passionate about
and mm-hmm just you got it you got to do
something that you're excited about you
got it something you want to have to
want to make a positive change somewhere
in some industry to help some community
to help some target market you have to
want to make that positive change in
impact you have to want it more than you
want the money mm-hmm because it's going
to be painful then you want to do it
anyway mm-hmm and the money won't
motivate you long enough
to go out and do it so we got to find
that thing and make that thing your goal
that's what I got and what do you think
what do you think about the whole a
Dodge what would you do if you were
never paid for it I really like that but
do you do you agree with that is that
something that you went by yeah I mean
that comes from a lot of different
famous entrepreneurs the one that's most
memorable to me is Oprah whoo-hoo
actually by the way we're in game I'm
timo jungle G arises rise mid so we're
looking good um Oh Alex those eggs smell
amazing he's listen I think he might
have headphones on just like this it
just this place just filled up with a
buttery smell that that's gonna be
really distracting okay um I think I'm
guy and Alec I know hey anje riser she
brings you some specialty coffee on on
friday so I'm yeah spoiled ungrateful um
I think of Oprah whoo-hoo after doing
her first kind of TV interview thing
said it felt like she was breathing for
the first time and then she said that
she would find you know jobs just to
make sure she could still do this if she
would never get paid to do it she would
still do it because she loved it so much
it felt like she was breathing and she
would do whatever she needed to do to
keep going on that path um and lots of
people said it in Alex those eggs felt
amazing well if you heard me anyway a
lot of people have said it in a lot of
different ways but but I agree you want
to find the thing that you would do even
if you wouldn't get paid for it because
you love it so much it fills a much
bigger purpose it's kind of like you
know uh I want to get married because I
want to have kids well that's not really
the best reason to want to get married
right that's great that's great and so
you know focus on the other things first
yes you know ideally you will have kids
but that's not the primary reason for
wanting to pick at least in my view
maybe other people feel that way but in
my view it's not the primary reason to
want to get married to somebody and so
it's the same thing with your business
idea you want to pick the thing that you
would do you would be with that person
even you couldn't have kids and you
you'd find another way maybe you adopt
or you know use a surrogate or whatever
the other options are it's the same
thing with business if you focus just on
the outcome instead of the process
you're not gonna have a success yeah oh
alright looks like the game is going
game is going Junior I switched to top I
didn't see what happened or why he did
that but he is now top and I'm jungle so
we got some we got the game on here so
far no one kills no deaths we're all
we're all even ok here we go next one
yep Bernhard morning says hey Evan I
just wanted to pick the time really
thank you for that video there are
really a number of tips and advice I
could use my social and communication
skills are not my strongest suit so
these videos really helped me out a lot
I was wondering if you have or otherwise
can make a video on clothing skills
something to help us finalize that sale
or to get more clients I find so much
worth in your videos you inspire me Evan
thank for that best regard for nerd
alright alright so you know I definitely
myself right now and learning a lot of
new things new things about
sales and I'm admittedly it's not my
comfort zone and not something that I
feel super strong in but what I'm
hearing across the board is I'm learning
from others who do it successfully is
that I mean there's all this you know
there's all this talk about the power of
persuasion or the power of influence and
all of that but for me what will make it
work for me at the end of the day is
believing in what it is that I'm selling
and truly believing that what I'm
selling is is absolutely benefiting the
person on the receiving end s but I
think that most salespeople who are
really successful that it comes down to
that that they they truly believe that
what they're doing is improving the
lives of the people around them and so I
think when you start with that it will
influence how you deal with people and
then you can maybe share some I don't
know about Pierce specific closing
techniques but i would just imagine that
every every part of the sales process
for me at least would feel i think more
effective if I believe that the product
is good and I want and I absolutely
believe it'll improve the lives of
people and any when you're excited about
something when you believe in something
it's kind of easy to then convince
others to be a part of two I love it
let's do a quick pause look at these
eggs and Alex just brought in hello
that's some quality of triple egg with
some toast or whatever that is I'm
digging it um I'm onda I'm on delay i
have an idiot oh it's coming up soon
then it's gonna come up soon oh yeah
they are Wow three of them three eggs
some yum yummy town we're hitting the
yummy tan okay I'm trying to help Jay
rising in a gank here can I do something
can I do something
yeah we gotta kill J reyez good job
that's teamwork up to teamwork up top
whoo liking that okay good times good
times I'm closing so I think the best
skill that you need to use is your ears
I think too and people are talking too
much without gaining understanding of
what the customer actually needs they
will you know I one-hundred percent
agree with Rishi in that you know I can
passionately advocate for a product or
service or solution when I absolutely
believe that it's the best thing for
them and I think I think a lot of people
maybe don't even push hard enough on
that on the sales side but it's pushing
not to not to just trying to make the
sale and hit your quota it's pushing to
help them get past whatever comfort zone
issues are having with it like if you
believe that this is the best thing for
them then then you owe it to them to go
out and really you know give it your all
to explain why you think it's really
going to benefit them but if they see
you as coming across as just like the
sales person trying to make a commission
then it seemed really hard to you know
that you get that kind of sleazy kind of
feel sometimes so where you know for me
it's a lot of even even within my team
you know I'm trying to push people to be
the best version of themselves and that
means going way outside you know their
comfort zone and stretching their
limiting personal beliefs and as soon as
I touch on it as soon as identify one
the immediate reaction is defensiveness
the immediate reaction is oh no that
that's that's not me or I don't want to
do that painful thing that I need to do
to break through but is going to be
important and it's all out of love and
care for them and that's what eventually
kind of gets us through is the
understanding that there I'm trying to
help them I'm not trying to sell them
anything I'm not do
for me it's for them and so it calls
into question the longer term value of
the relationship mm-hmm the best
salespeople the ones that you can hahaha
sorry I'm in the middle of a fight here
it's getting getting testy the best
salespeople are the ones that you can
not just have a one-time transaction
with but you want to have a long-term
relationship with like sometimes I turn
away deals that would benefit me in the
short run but they come back because
listen at that time what you wanted was
not what I could give you I'm not the
best guy for you recognizing that i'm
not the best for everybody and just
trying to convince them that my ideas
are you know solid it's coming from
listening to them and understanding what
their real needs are and sometimes that
means turning away business but the next
time they're going to come back to you
because they trusted you they appreciate
your advice and so it's using your ears
really trying to understand what they
care about really try understand if
you're going to be the best fit for them
and then approaching the intention of
you want to help these people and I
think that can also help you get through
a lot of the for people who aren't used
to selling who feel it's a dirty thing I
think it get help you get through this
like listen these guys have real
problems you know it may not be a
life-changing problem all the time you
know if you're selling you know
breakfast at whatever restaurant you
have that may not be a life-changing
problem that you're solving but
understand you there trying to help them
instead of trying to sell them and just
shifting that mindset can make a big
difference if you're if you feel like
selling is you know for dirty people or
scamming people and you don't want to be
associated with that and the good news
is we're all equipped to help we are all
already equipped to help and so Oh under
attack war way
okay there we go all right we're good I
made it I got I got jumped on um you
like helping people right like we all
have the tools are ready to help people
and if you have the expertise in an
industry right whatever whatever it is
for me it's entrepreneurship you have
whatever you do if you have those
expertise and you combine that with the
ability to help with desire to help and
you're making sales so it doesn't have
to be this dirty thing just listening
and adjusting your mindset I think will
help absolutely yeah we got some chatter
in the in the box with got um Jen so
much saying you know if it's not a match
no biggie just in terms of sales and you
know working with someone if it's not a
match no biggie just what make a
decision all done with love so I think
that makes a good point too is like one
of the things that I think can be hard
is people are comfortable with that
having to make that decision and
sometimes people don't just say yes I
want it or no I don't want it so so
other people's inability to say yes I
want or no I don't want it can I say
make it a awkward situation for the
sales person don't you think yeah I had
something to say and then we got into a
fight here the chaos um sooo the
question again I want well it should you
know the sales person might actually be
totally fine with hey I'm going to push
you because I think this was going to be
good for you but at the end of the day
if you're not interested you know just
say no and I think the awkwardness of
sales can be at times that people don't
know how to handle that being pushed and
they don't know how to they don't have
their own personal boundaries to say you
know oh no this just isn't for me it's
it just can be an awkward dynamic when
when the person who's being sold to
doesn't have the boundaries to say I'm
not interested or I am interested sure
and knowing how far you can push
somebody I think people don't push
enough in general and and are afraid of
being that pushy salesperson where again
you're looking at it from a perspective
of helping them um I remember what I
wanted this I wanted to say that a works
going back I wanted to say that I think
a lot of people stay with the wrong
potential clients too long like I would
if somebody's not a fit I would rather
know that and then spend more time with
people who are potential fits then
follow up and follow up and follow up
and follow and follow with people who
are who are not fits for what I'm doing
mm-hmm and it's kind of it's a it's a
super classic sales technique I guess of
you know keep following up and keep
following up and keep following up and
me now maybe that works for a lot of
people for me I would rather just spend
the time with people who value what I'm
doing and if you don't get it and you
don't have the need I don't want to call
you you know every single day and bother
you about this I'd rather go on and move
to somebody else who sees the value has
the need has the budgets we ready to
move forward yeah
cool so let me give you a game update
because we're doing that we're doing
well here seven kills 21 death the team
team oh is that has two of those kills
so I'm to a no pretty exciting happening
yeah things are happening things are
happening guys this might be the start
of a new streak bring on the street
hashtag bring on the streak cold all
right next question is coming from roca
rochas yeah so roca says hello Evan can
you give me advice how to start I want
to inspire others to be yourself and
spire people to be different that being
different is not that a bad thing and i
always i've already done it for some
people personally but how to create a
business with this idea in my country at
least from the point from my point of
view i do not see that someone makes
something like I want to can you help me
I don't want I don't know where else to
ask already well I definitely love the
vision I love the idea of helping people
be more comfortable being themselves and
being different is ok I know there's
there's a lot of inspirational people
out there who are giving that message
but I think it's a message that we still
need to hear every day you know more
more people giving permission to others
to just be themselves even if they don't
quote unquote fit in so um i think
you're right i think what i would've
would tell you real guess is that it
kind of seems like you're in your own
way and left had actually evan we were
having some a little bit of chat about
self sabotage we talked about that on
friday and to me when you are
for someone in your country to have done
it first or you're just you know you
already have everything you need right
now essentially I mean YouTube is
available for you right now you could
start making videos today and share your
heart for how you want to help people
and immediately get something going I
know that YouTube is a slower a slower
business model but the point is just
that there's nothing holding you back
really so I would just find a way to
start and if you've already done it in
the lives of people around you you know
ask them what did it what did i do in
your life that helps you like what
specifically did I do that brought value
and that would give you some ideas as
maybe what to how to continue to give
value whether it's in a youtube or a
blog or or anything so yeah I think it's
great that no one else in your country
is doing it because that's probably why
you're supposed to do it I'm feeling the
love and Rishi um you know there's a lot
of different ways to be able to monetize
this thing when I first started doing
what I was doing I had no idea how I was
gonna make money right I was doing
seminars I did it at the YMCA and it was
really just an experiment a test to try
to see in it ended up working out which
is great um but i didn't i didn't know
however i thought i wouldn't ever make
money at it I thought because I can only
get you know those three people to show
up to my free event that I'd never be
able to make any substantial income from
it but I kept doing it so the thing is
you have to figure out how the execution
is going to be unique for you right so
are you better at this is great that
you've done it with some of your friends
and what have
you are you better at coaching where
you're meeting people one-on-one and
you're helping them break through there
you know limiting beliefs are you better
at doing videos are you better creating
you know worksheets what what are you
better at me what are you we have any
important what's the execution that is
so great for you that's what you need to
figure out and then hone those skills so
if you're great at coaching let's
example right you you like meeting with
people and over a cup of coffee or
series of coffees you can move somebody
to take action right say that's what
you're all about perfect now you need to
perfect that system so you can get there
faster and more effectively what needs
to get done for you to be able to do
that faster right so now you're still
honing your skills you're still you know
you're probably okay at it you've had
some experience great you got to do it
better faster right impact more people
more quickly how do you get there how
can you do it so that instead of it
taking you you know three months worth
of conversations you can do it you know
in one month or in one conversation
right understanding that will be where
you can really then start to shine so
there's a lot of different ways like if
you can do that quickly then people
start paying you for that right if I can
meet in a cup of coffee and I come out
changed then you can charge you for that
you know right now you may not be able
to start charging not because you're not
providing the value yet it's just more
you haven't been like it takes too long
to get there may not be a repeatable
process yet you know like look at my
youtube channel how many videos have I
done how much practice that i had and i
still have a long way to go right like i
might like my videos and they may
inspire you and I'm you know super
humbled by all that but I still have a
long way to go to be where I want to be
it'll be more practice
more practice and for practice but i
found my execution like I don't want to
do the one-on-one coaching as much I
want to do it in a more public setting I
want to do it through videos I want to
do it through you know the books that
I'm creating and so you know just
because nobody in your country has done
it yet that's fine that's that's the
life of an entrepreneur right like we
see something that nobody else sees and
we go out and we make something happen
that's all I soon whoa whoa under attack
under attack under attack can I get at
it can I get out as a question can I get
out of the big question whoa all right
I'm running I think I'm gonna make it oh
I'm gonna make it I made it whew that
was scary that was scary town guys that
was scary town oh yeah so you know like
I look at I look at when I was starting
my industry again nobody had done what I
was doing that's literally and just just
finding like one keep going because if
you love it you have to keep going and
then finding the right model for you
that combines your skills and what you
want to learn so that you can really
shine like just because somebody else is
having success with YouTube videos it
doesn't mean you have to go and do
YouTube videos right you have to find
the execution that's right for you you
know and a lot of that comes from
practice so keep practicing coaching
people practice making videos practice
doing interviews practice doing seminars
why do you love the most what makes you
excited because when you get really good
at that thing and people walk away
feeling like they've gotten so much in
same value from it then you'll start
making a lot of money from it
yeah and I think going back to the very
first question we had one way to kind of
determine your execution would be what
would you do if no one paid you for it I
feel like that's a good way to tap into
where your where your you will shine
because i know for me and someone asked
me that question i immediately my mind
went to what i'm doing on rishi cup TV
the video for me is what I've always
loved but uh you might think when
someone asks you that question what
would you do no one paid you for you
might think you know a blog or you know
coaching or whatever so that's it and
then you always envisioned did you
always out exactly good luck when
someone if someone were to ask you that
question and then like when you were
well you want to be a banker right outta
you wanted to be in the banking after
after college but like did you ever see
this like has this unfolded almost as a
surprise to you or was this something
that you could actually see years before
for yourself uh no I had no idea okay
yeah I had no idea I but I was willing
like I came out I did the first
presentation because I had some success
as an entrepreneur and and I thought
yeah I be cool the sure why not I got
invited to do something I said yeah I'm
happy to do it saying yes to things like
when you don't know what it is and you
explore you explored till you find
anything that you want to do so I didn't
know what I wanted to do so I had to
explore and then I eventually found it
whoa can I save my team can I save my
team hey the fight is real the fight is
real
I got a kill and an assist oh all right
yeah when you don't know what you want
to do you gotta gotta explore and try
and see ya so I said one I said yes to
11 interview and that turned into you
know a lot more and it could have sucked
in him but you know it didn't so but I
said I said yes to a lot of other stuff
that did suck nothing that I was not
good at and that I didn't want to
continue getting better at and that was
the one like this is one of the one of
the things that hit um so I got you know
i can say i was fortunate in that but I
created that situation might just saying
yes I said yes so salsa dancing right
yes the salsa yeah when I said yes other
things too that did not do well and you
saw it actually became the thing that I
stuck with for years mm-hmm when it
didn't make you no logical sense for me
to do so you got to explore until you
find the thing that you really love
doing yeah and the reason I appreciate
that during that process and then it's
because it goes back to the thing of
like when people say well what do I do
and you know you should say we'll just
start and that's the thing about when
you just start is that once you start
things come to you that you never could
have planned and so part of it is like
realizing that I mean not to get too
deep but like it's almost like life
hands you more when you are in action
and in motion and so I don't know I just
think some of it is like nothing will
start if you don't start nothing will
come to you you don't just do something
you know so sure I mean even the
this like League of Legends I saw you
know junior eyes wouldn't used to come
over to the office and I saw him
watching this game and I thought it was
I thought it was you know I thought it
was interesting he was spending his time
on it and I thought I never thought that
I would be that I would this wasn't my
kind of game like I never really enjoyed
this kind of stuff but I asked him what
a why don't we make a video teach me how
to play league of legends and so we made
a video and and I kind of liked it and
send we you know now it became this
whole thing is part of my daily routine
you know hmm would it get you know I
don't know but I you know just saying
yes and trying things and then seeing
how you feel about it the
experimentation is important totally all
right good luck just look at the chatter
over here Evan all right I'm being
chased hard lucky I got it whoo okay
what's not currently not doesn't look
like the chatter chatters are people
talking to each other right now Oh with
it talking to themselves oh who would
they talk to to know the others are kind
of talking to each other they're like
you know we got some yeah non-related
chatter though all right I like it all
right yeah next question comes from
Daniel and Daniel says hit Evan really
thrilled yeah I'm really thrilled to
actually be communicating with you your
videos are a real encouragement right
now I'm facing a difficult situation I'm
nearly broke and have to choose between
getting a day job or continuing to fight
for my dreams I'm praying for a miracle
from Daniel artist in Ohio
yes alrighty so it doesn't look like
there's really a question here Evan but
looks like he's just meeting some
encouragement looks like pretty feeling
he's still in the urgency of having to
choose between a day job and dreams and
you know a lot of the people that I
really respect who are doing their
dreams and who fought for their dreams
like you were mentioning Oprah you know
she she did what she had to do even if
it meant other job to continue doing
what was her green same thing for going
back to Elizabeth Gilbert from that top
10 she actually said that a part of part
of her commitment to her dream was that
she would never ever require it to be
like for her writing is her dream and so
she said she was never going to write
for money she would do whatever she can
to sustain that dream but she was not
going to demand that the dream was what
had to provide for her and so that for
her that meant being a waitress for
years same thing with Barbara from shark
tank I think she did a lot a lot a lot
of jobs before she did I think she said
recently like I had like 20 plus jobs
before her main real estate success so I
don't think it's one or the other I
think it's part of the journey for a lot
of people you know I think if it really
is your dream then sometimes it means
having to maybe do some stuff that
you're not so excited about to keep the
dream going um I don't think you're in a
unique situation and I don't think you
need to see it as you're giving up on
your group because you have to get a day
job ah but hey I don't know Evan you
might have
they're protected her for Daniel you
gotta kill hold on timo got it Oh almost
a double kill all right good we're doing
well uh yeah it's both it's both it's
both you don't do one or the other it's
not your day job or your dream it's both
you do what you need to do all right to
get to make a hat like it'll take me
take it takes longer than you think it's
gonna take if that means going out you
have to go get a job to support yourself
listen you gotta you gotta survive you
gotta you gotta eat food you need to pay
your internet bill right both warm we
won hey um and then here you like you
have this thing you can feel like a step
backwards it can feel like a step
backwards to go back and get a job and
let me just say good game to everybody
here changing play it all nice I got it
s + + J reyez got an S Plus that's two
best to in the home I like I finished
four kills no deaths ten Jared's had 10
kills three deaths so it's we did we did
pretty well there it can feel like a
step backwards you can feel like I step
backwards too especially if you were
full time when you were doing it for a
year or six months or 18 months whatever
it was and then and then you stopped you
know you run out of money and you have
to go back get a job it feels like
you're giving up the key thing is that
you're making every day some some kind
of forward progress and it's not it's
not a huge step back it's just like it's
not it's not fatal as long as you keep
going there's lots of people who have to
do that who want to be a musician or who
want to be a you know a software
entrepreneur who want to be win or
whatever it is fill in the blank
whatever your dream is I may not come as
fast as you want and that may be
humbling and that you need to go in and
get a job and ideally you go get a job
where you're going to learn something
too right we've talked about that yeah
if you're going to go back and get a job
it's something that you know hey you
know what I haven't had success in my
entrepreneurial ventures because I don't
know about marketing okay great go get a
marketing job right go get something
that where you can learn about marketing
so that you can have success while you
continue to build your business it's
just it's only fatal if you stop if you
stop your company right just not working
on it and you just shelve it if you give
up on it where you need to be spending
that 30 to 60 minutes every day on the
business to help it continue to grow
mm-hmm I love to what Tyler Perry says I
think that the tagline of his company is
where dreams dream for you and the idea
is that like when it really is a dream
in you that that is you know the real
deal no matter what happens in the
process like that dream is going to keep
living and you will get there even if
you don't get there as fast as you want
like your your dream when you can't
dream for your dream anymore it
continues on so I think when it's really
something you've got to do no matter
what the process you're going to get
there very cool well hey we predicted
start of a streak that was those how we
led this off and here we are with a
victory so pretty pumped about that
Rishi is going to close this off with a
message of the day what do we got oh I
am feeling a just cup of appreciation
for everyone in the chat and everyone
showing up and asking questions and just
you know I I think what I what I'm
feeling is that none of us can do this
by ourselves and it's so awesome to be
able to come somewhere and for an hour
chat with each other and
each other learn together I think super
valuable no I love it I love it feeling
the warm feelings I rishi spreading some
some warm love that cool uh well thank
you guys for joining will be back on
again tomorrow morning hopefully
continue on our streak have an amazing
day I believe in you and I hope you
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you soon